I don't want to spend a ton of time on
Bernie's reaction to Kirsten Cinema
leaving the Democratic party but I do
think it's important and interesting
because Bernie also is an independent
who is made very very clear I caucus
with the Democrats and there are
specific reasons why Bernie is an
independent Vermont is also a unique
state in terms of its political
orientation and Alignment Vermont
Republicans are different than National
Republicans and gun ownership is a
different thing in Vermont we've talked
about sort of the interesting different
dynamics of Vermont Bernie Sanders
appeared on CNN to talk about I mean he
I don't know that he appeared to talk
about Kirsten Cinema but Dana Bash
certainly talked to him about it and he
was pretty clear he's not super
impressed with Kirsten Cinema calls her
a corporate Democrat and says quite a
few accurate but critical things about
her let's take a listen to what Bernie
had to say you are an independent she is
now the third official independent of
the U.S Senate joining you in Angus King
of Maine what do you think of her
decision and also what you just heard in
her interview with Jake
I don't want to spend a whole lot of
time on Senator Cinema she has her
reasons uh Donna I happen to suspect
that it's probably a lot to do uh with
politics back in Arizona I think are the
Democrats there are not all that
enthusiastic about somebody who helps
sabotage some of the most important
legislation that protects the interests
of working families and so that's that's
a pretty clear shot across the bow
voting rights and and so forth so I
think it really has to do with her uh
political aspirations uh for the future
in Arizona but for us I think nothing
much has changed in terms of the
functioning of the U.S Senate the good
news is that we now have uh 51 votes
we'll have a majority on committees it
means that we can go forward and start
protecting the interests the Working
Families and deal with the reality that
we are increasingly living in an
oligarchy where the billionaire class
and large corporations uh control almost
every aspect of of our country so I
would hope very much that with this
Newman charity Democrats will sit down
and start fighting for the needs of
ordinary Americans so I want to talk
about some of those issues in a second
but first you know you were a very
important figure on the campaign Trail
for progressives ahead of the midterms
as you normally are I'm sure you're
going to be campaigning for candidates
in 2024. the outgoing Arizona Democratic
Party official uh one of them says that
he expects Democrats will run their own
candidate against her is that a good
idea would you support a democratic
opponent against Senator Cinema good
question
I support Progressive candidates all
over this country people who have the
guts to take on powerful special
interests I don't know what's going to
be happening in Arizona we'll see who
they nominate but certainly that's
something I will take a hard look at
does she have the guts to take on
powerful special interests
no no she is a corporate Democrat uh who
has in fact along with Senator manchin
sabotaged enormously important
legislation so two sides to this of
course number one
to the extent that Kirsten Cinema will
caucus with Democrats and mostly
continue voting with Democrats even if
she is a Centrist corporate Democrat as
Bernie says her vote is still useful and
if 60 votes are needed at least
plausibly that's one fewer Republican
vote that would be necessary fine but at
the same time Bernie is clear about
Kirsten Cinema's political views and as
we've seen over the last two years
there's been a lot of playing koi with
her supposed Independence which is
really Center rightism at the end of the
day Bernie's being very clear while
being sort of diplomatic we really can't
say much more about how the next two
years are going to go without seeing how
they go it's just guesswork and
predicting as the bills start being
voted on we're very quickly going to
learn much more about it but good to see
that Bernie isn't confused about what's
going on here